the final speaker session is from Adobe
talking about designing delivering
experiences using e-learning it my name
is Daniel kammath and I run the ML AI
group Adobe for the experience cloud
business so many of you might be
wondering what the experience cloud is
so I'll start off a little bit by
telling you like when you think of Adobe
what what is the first thing that comes
to mind yeah Photoshop but there is a
whole other side of Adobe which probably
you guys interact with but don't
probably know that you're interacting
with so there's the document cloud which
is PDF Acrobat there is the Creative
Cloud which is Photoshop Illustrator but
there is the other business which is the
experience cloud which powers a lot of
the digital marketing and advertising
that branch do we offer that as a
software as a service that enables
brands like Citibank fold to run their
website their email campaigns their apps
their social marketing their videos
videos that they create and show on
their various properties as well as
things which involve advertising on
third-party sites like Google or
Facebook or or any of the web sites
so in fact we power a lot of the top
brands so most likely the email that you
receive or the website that you go to
from for any any of the top brands is
likely powered by by the Adobe's
experienced cloud business it's just
that we are working behind the scenes a
name and and enabling it so you won't
see that when you go to that website
directly
so what are we seeing in why did we call
it the experience cloud business I think
what we saw was a lot of the brands are
seeing this transformation there people
don't just buy products and services
they are going to these brands because
they want a certain kind of experience
so I when I was booking my ticket I was
talking to my wife and she says oh I
prefer to buy it from so-and-so airline
because I'm so used to the user
interface I get notifications when the
flights get delayed I know when my
baggage is loaded onto the airplane so
it's not just the physical experience
it's also the digital experience which
plays a significant role in how
consumers interact with the brands and
decide whether they like or don't like a
brand and from the consumers point of
view what they're looking for is a
consistent continuous and compelling
experience across all the different
channels so just to give an example I
was in Las Vegas a couple of weeks ago
at a at our conference and I woke up in
the morning I opened the Starbucks app
it knew that I was in Las Vegas it knew
where I was it pointed me to the closest
Starbucks it asked me whether I wanted
my usual mocha which I said yes I
clicked on it by the time I arrived at
the Starbucks I didn't have to wait and
that huge line that of people waiting to
get the coffee I could just bypass them
pick up my coffee and I was I was there
right that's the experience it is like
it knows it's personalized it knows what
I want it knows where I am
it knows once I order it to have it
ready for me in that physical location
where I'm going to be there so that's
the kind of experience that consumers
increasingly demand of the brands that
they work with so from from the people
in these brands the marketing guys the
advertising guys what they need to
figure out is how do i how do i make
this experience personalized how do i
make it
relevant to what the consumer has done
based on what they have done in the past
and how do I adjust in real time to
everything that I know about that person
whether the location of the person where
they are what time it is all of those
things right so so Millennials
especially I mean they are they have
they are used to growing up in this
world of where everything is digital and
they they they expect that all brands
are able to provide this for them not
just not just the new new companies that
have arisen in this digital only world
so of course experiences start with
great content but most importantly what
we see is that experiences are powered
by data right and that's where machine
learning and AI plays a very
increasingly important role so just to
give you a flavor on behalf of our
brands we collect a large amount of data
so we as I said power websites apps
social media advertising videos all of
that data plus we get other brands to
give us other data maybe visits to their
physical branch offices or to their
calls to the call center in addition we
deliver a lot of content you deliver a
lot of experiences in the digital side
so together this creates a vast pool of
data so what what essentially is
happening is that this always on always
connected consumer is also creating a
lot of data for us which can then be
used to deliver to their great expect to
their big expectations right
are you provide sort of a IML as a
software service model yeah for their
customers in their business how much
that dinner passes to your platform yes
so the data belongs to the brands we are
the operator that in the sense we
collect the data on their behalf we help
analyze and understand and we help them
deliver the experiences through the
channels that we offer them services
against so we have an analytics product
which collects the data through tracking
mechanisms we have mechanisms where they
can transfer data to us we have audience
Manager which allows them to manage
their customer profiles we have various
delivery mechanisms so we have service
that enables people to create and
personalize their websites through
testing recommendations personalization
we have the ability to send emails and
notifications so we allow their digital
marketers to figure out how to run their
email campaigns their mobile app
notifications as well as the various
acquisition channels that they use like
Facebook or Google or the display ad
networks through which they acquire
customers so all of these things we are
doing on behalf of the brand in that
sense it's very different from the
googles and Facebooks of the world where
they are trying to optimize revenue that
they generating on their properties we
are enabling sort of the other side
which is enabling the branch to figure
out how to use their data to run
effective marketing and advertising
campaigns across these different
channels that they touch their consumers
Consulting yes we do it more as a SAS
model we work with other partners if
they want to create consulting practices
on on top of it but we what we sell is
SAS solutions
so so this data that I talked about is
large right it is high dimensional it's
also real time in the sense it's
constantly coming in at very high speeds
and to take that data make sense out of
it make predictions based on it and then
actually act against it is what we call
the experience intelligence right so
that's that's what that's what my group
is responsible for driving so to
simplify it what what we are doing with
this data is taking this data and
enabling the brands to get intelligent
insights who are my consumers what are
they doing what do they want what what
is the so to describe experience in a
nutshell it would be figuring out what
content to show which consumer in a
specific context right so the right
thing the right content at the right
place to the right person bringing that
together as the experience and taking a
whole amount of data that comes from
experiences and then creating that
intelligent insights into who the
consumer is what what's the different
content that they they are engaging with
and what is the context and channel
through which they are engaging with
with that content and then using it
enabling it to be used for designing
campaigns designing marketing and
advertising campaigns and actually
delivering the campaign is is what what
we are enabling
so I will get you get into one example
of how this works and maybe we can then
dig deeper into how to generalize it but
that's sort of in a nutshell what what
we are trying to do so let's look at the
experience when you go to a website like
CNN and then there is this slot here
where you want to show something right
now behind this behind this particular
slot out there there's a whole complex
ecosystem of systems and decisions that
decides what's going to what's going to
show up there
so CNN will of course when the person
comes through a browser or through
through a mobile phone to this website
CNN will of course deliver the page with
all the news and other stuff but what
happens in this this particular slot is
that there is an ad tag this ad tag
calls supply-side platform which is
think of supply-side platform as
something which is helping the publisher
figure out which among the different ads
it should be showing in that particular
particular particular slot so the supply
side platform connects with a large
number of demand side demand-side
platforms which are essentially
aggregators of advertisers who are
trying to show their ad in this
particular slot so you might have Ford
or you might have Citibank and you might
have Nordstrom all of them want to that
gets displayed or have their ad
displayed in in this in this particular
slot the supply side form platform is
just enabling these different people to
come back with a bid and an ad to be
shown in that particular spot
so these different demand-side platforms
will come back with a response in which
there is a bid which indicates I am
willing to pay this much for an
impression to be shown to this
particular person on this in this
particular slot and the supply side
platform will run an auction which takes
all the bids figure out the highest bid
and whoever wins that bid it will direct
to the winning ad server so say the
first ad server was a winning one so it
gets redirected the ad server request
gets redirected to that demand side
platform and the ad server at that point
will redirect it to the CDM which is the
con content network like Akamai for
example and the CDN will then then show
the ad in that particular spot so that's
sort of at a high level what's happening
in this slot in terms of what is
happening behind the scenes before an ad
gets displayed in this particular slot
let's dig a little bit deeper into one
of these demand-side platforms and see
what's happening underneath that so they
think of the demand side platform as a
place where different advertisers so
adobe has a demand side platform in
which we are enabling different brands
to figure out how to run their
advertising campaigns and identify the
consumers where they want to show an ad
to and the sites on which they want to
show the ad ad so the brands are
creating campaigns so the campaigns
indicate how much dollars they have in
terms of how much they're willing to
spend on that advertising campaign they
have specific targets maybe in terms of
audiences they want to reach they have
our Y metrics in terms of certain goal
or metrics they want to hit and the
budget of course and under which those
metrics have to be have to be met there
is a user profile which indicates for
each user what what is the information
that we know about that user some of
them might be things that we have gotten
through the analytics that we have on
the on the website of those brands some
of them may be things that we got to get
from third-party data the others would
be things that we predict about that
user maybe their propensity to buy that
specific kind of product or their
propensity or interest in a specific
kind of content then there is the
context in which the ad is going to be
placed and as the example I gave you we
know that this ad is going to be shown
on the CNN homepage the person we know
or the browser we know is at a specific
location we know which kind of device
that requests for that page is coming
from we might know other things about
that page as well as about about that
location that we could use so that is
sort of your information that you can
get from from the from the website on
based on which you have to make a
bidding bidding decision so you take all
of this information the profile the bed
request information the context
information the campaign targets and
then you based on that you have to
decide for each campaign how much is it
worth to show a specific ad to this
particular person on this specific
location at this time right so you might
have a limited budget in which you might
be very picky and qu you get to pick and
choose the impressions or you might have
a lot of budget in which you might have
lacks laxer restrictions in terms of
filters that you run against boohoo
we want to show you add two you might
have a lot of information about the user
and which you really want to get that
user you there's a whole whole set of
information that plays a role in that
decision of whether you want to bid and
if you want to bid how much you want to
bid and when you bid
what's the ad you want to show to that
should show that that person so that's
sort of the complexity of the decision
that goes into creating there's one
experience of showing an ad to one
consumer on a very specific site you dig
deeper into the user profile there's a
whole set of other things that come into
play which is you have of course the web
analytics what the person did on your
website so if I'm City Bank I know what
what kind of things a consumer who comes
to my website has expressed interest in
but there's also other information that
I can add based on if I can connect that
cookie of that person to an account I
know
fraud for that account that that person
has a mortgage or that the person
visited a branch office which was in a
specific location or that person had
called a call center there's a whole
bunch of other set of information that
you can then connect with that that
identity to get a richer in profile for
that user but there are some things
which you have to predict which is how
likely that person is going to engage
with an offer for a fixed for a CD with
a certain percentage of interest or what
likely like likelihood is that person
interest in a certain kind of content or
a certain kind of credit card so that's
that's what falls into the bucket of the
customer intelligence which we have to
take the data that we have and then
based on that build these predictions
the I don't have much time but I'll
quickly go into a couple more things
which is these things don't happen in
silos these experiences
I showed are part of a bigger customer
journey the customer might interact with
the brand's through multiple different
touch points before ending ending up
making a purchase and the understanding
of the journey is as important as
understanding of these individual
experiences so journey design is one of
the critical things that many brands and
marketers spend a lot of effort in in
order to figure out how to connect a
bunch of experiences to give that
customer a nice smooth experience
towards getting them to a specific
outcome and in this journey optimization
you have several decisions that you end
up making what is the offer that I
should show that person what is the best
time to send an email to that person
what is the call center script that I
should serve that person which channel
should I reach the customer through
should I send them something through an
app should I send them something through
an SMS message or something through an
email all of these decisions you need
tools to help figure out what is the
best mechanism in order to make that
journey smooth and easy for the for the
end consumer
so I guess I don't have much time but so
these things play also a role in the
return on investment for advertising
that people that the brands look for
understanding the journey means figuring
out which things which which touch
points in the journey contribute how
much towards getting that person person
to a final outcome which goes into
figuring out media planning how much
money I allocate towards these various
channels and it also flows into how how
I manage my campaigns so if you look at
the problems there's a lot of different
problems and understanding consumers
understanding how to create these
experiences there's a lot of problems
around how do you connect these
different experiences to get a cust
customers journey and then finally how
do you figure out based on these
different experiences and journeys how
do you allocate your media dollars and
your marketing dollars across these
different options that you have that's
that's what a nutshell
thank you okay so if all the speakers
could come up and then they'll ship to
general Q&A